Esta mujer que veis en pantalla es Alexandria
OCASIO CORTEZ, la mujer que quiere convertir
a Estados Unidos en la nueva Suecia. Se trata
de la congresista más joven de la historia
de Estados Unidos y una de las caras más
conocidas del Partido Demócrata. Se define
abiertamente como socialista democrática.
Tiene millones de seguidores en twitter y
otros tantos millones de críticos, tanto
fuera como dentro de su propio partido. Pensadlo
bien: en un país como Estados Unidos, la
palabra “socialista” levanta muchas ampollas.
Sin embargo, en un momento donde los demócratas
están en plena crisis de identidad, su discurso
parece la fórmula ganadora para las próximas
elecciones. Pero ¿Qué defiende, exactamente,
Ocasio Cortez? ¿Qué es el socialismo democrático?
En este vídeo, te lo vamos a explicar.
Hace unos meses, sacamos un vídeo en VisualPolitik
hablando del cambio ideológico dentro del
Partido Republicano con Donald Trump. Pues
en el Partido Demócrata está ocurriendo
algo muy parecido. A fin de cuentas, cuando
un partido pierde unas elecciones, los afiliados
se preguntan el por qué. Y ahí es cuando
surgen propuestas de todo tipo.
En este caso, podemos hablar de toda una nueva
generación de políticas demócratas que
ya han roto varios records. Y sí, digo políticas
porque casi todas las integrantes de este
grupo son mujeres. Por ejemplo, tenemos a
ILHAN OMAR y RASHIDA TLAIB, que son las primeras
musulmanas en llegar al Congreso. De hecho,
ILHAM OMAR será también la primera congresista
que lleva un velo islámico. Además del género
y la edad, esta nueva hornada de políticas
se define por tener una enorme presencia en
redes sociales y tener unas ideas totalmente
rompedoras dentro del partido demócrata tradicional.
Pero, sin duda alguna, la representante más
famosa de este nuevo movimiento es esta mujer
que veis en pantalla: Alexandria Ocasio Cortez,
la gran abanderada del llamado socialismo
democrático.
Como os podéis imaginar, Ocasio Cortez se
ha convertido en seguida en el blanco de todas
las críticas de la derecha. Pero no os equivoquéis:
la vieja guardia del partido demócrata tampoco
la ve con buenos ojos. Por ejemplo: una de
sus grandes propuestas políticas es el llamado
“Green New Deal”, que es un paquete de
medidas sociales y ecológicas. Sin embargo,
ni siquiera la portavoz de los Demócratas,
Nancy Pelosi, está de acuerdo con este proyecto.
Es más, en algunas entrevistas ha llegado
a despreciarlo abiertamente. No deja de ser
sorprendente teniendo en cuenta que ambas
están en el mismo partido político.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos:
esto del socialismo democrático no es nada
nuevo en Estados Unidos. A fin de cuentas,
es lo mismo que defendía Bernie Sanders en
las primarias demócratas de 2016. Y sí,
tenéis razón. La diferencia es que ahora
no sólo hablamos de un candidato aislado
sino de todo un movimiento que parece cada
vez más amplio ¡Pero no sólo eso! Bernie
Sanders podía ser muy de izquierdas en lo
económico pero cuando llegábamos a los temas
sociales era mucho más moderado. Por ejemplo,
no se oponía frontalmente al derecho a portar
armas y, en temas de inmigración o incluso
de raza, podía pasar por un conservador.
Sin embargo, tanto Ocasio Cortez como sus
compañeras son un punto y aparte en los demócratas.
Y, tal vez, un punto y aparte en la política
de Estados Unidos. Así que la pregunta es
¿Es posible que uno de los países más capitalistas
del mundo termine adoptando un sistema socialista?
¿Qué clase de socialismo propone Ocasio
Cortez? ¿De verdad tiene algo que ver con
el modelo nórdico, el de países como Suecia
o Dinamarca, que dicen seguir? Hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes, vamos
a ver un poco de historia.
NUEVAS CARAS, VIEJAS IDEAS
Ya sé lo que estáis pensando muchos. De
hecho, ya me puedo imaginar lo que me vais
a poner muchos en los comentarios: ¿Socialistas
en el partido demócrata? ¡Venga ya! En Estados
Unidos no existe una izquierda de verdad.
Aunque también sé que muchos otros, sobretodo
los que estéis viendo este vídeo desde el
mismo Estados Unidos, me diréis que el Partido
Demócrata siempre ha sido socialista, anticapitalista
y amante de los estados fuertes, que suben
los impuestos y encorsetan el mercado. Y lo
cierto es que ambos tenéis una pizca de razón.
Hablamos de uno de los partidos políticos
más antiguos del mundo. Tienen casi 200 años
de historia y eso es mucho tiempo para cambiar
de principios. Para que os hagáis una idea,
durante todo el siglo XIX, los políticos
que defendían la esclavitud pertenecían
al partido demócrata. Es más, incluso décadas
después de que Abraham Lincoln, que fue el
primer presidente republicano, aboliera la
esclavitud, muchos demócratas defendían
cosas como esta.
Hemos reorganizado el Partido Demócrata bajo
una única premisa, que esto es un país de
hombres blancos y que los hombres blancos
tienen que gobernarlo” –Benjamin Tillman,
Senador Demócrata por Carolina del Norte
de 1895 hasta 1918
Por supuesto que todo esto ha cambiado radicalmente.
Hoy en día, el Partido Demócrata no tiene
nada de racista. Pero este ejemplo nos sirve
para ver cómo los partidos pueden evolucionar
ideológicamente. Y algo parecido pasa con
la economía. En los años 30, Franklin Roosevelt
introdujo cambios radicales en el sistema
estadounidense. Subidas de impuestos, estado
del bienestar y muchísimas medidas para regular
a las empresas. Sin embargo, la administración
de Bill Clinton, o incluso la de Barack Obama
fueron muchísimo más moderadas.
Soy un ferviente creyente del libre mercado.
Soy un ferviente creyente del capitalismo.
Pero también soy un ferviente creyente de
que hay algunos bienes comunes (…) que requieren
alguna regulación. –Barack Obama
En otras palabras, que el Partido Demócrata
engloba a toda una amalgama de ideologías
que van desde el centro hasta la izquierda.
Por ejemplo, ABIGAIL SPANBERG es una de estas
políticas que pertenece a la llamada “blue
dog coalition”, que es el núcleo centrista
del partido. Pero también tenemos a los más
radicales. Y dentro de este grupo, la cara
más reconocible es nuestra protagonista de
hoy, Alexandria Ocasio Cortez. En una entrevista
a la cadena PBS, la preguntaron si esto del
socialismo democrático era algo así como
el fin del capitalismo… y esta fue su respuesta.
Creo que vamos a ver una evolución sin precedentes
en nuestro sistema económico y es difícil
decir qué dirección va a tomar. –Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez.
Pero, como decíamos antes… No es la única.
Por ejemplo, ILHAN OMAR, la primera Somalí
en llegar al congreso, también se identifica
como demócrata socialista. Sin embargo, en
este caso es tan radical en sus propuestas
que ni siquiera los propios socialistas la
admiten en el grupo ¿Por qué? Básicamente,
por su posición en contra de los asentamientos
y la ocupación militar de Israel en los territorios
palestinos. Si veis este vídeo desde España,
por ejemplo, seguramente no os parezcan posiciones
demasiado radicales. Pero en Estados Unidos
se trata de una de las cosas más controvertidas
que se pueden decir.
Es decir, que esta nueva oleada de políticas
demócratas están rompiendo muchos esquemas.
Mientras hacemos este vídeo, están investigando
al Deutsche bank por prestar dinero a Donald
Trump y han llegado a calificar al banco alemán
como uno de los mayores blanqueadores de dinero
del mundo.
Y todo esto, estando a las puertas de unas
elecciones primarias. Muchas de estas congresistas
se pudrían presentar a candidatas demócratas
para las presidenciales. Y eso significa que
la próxima presidenta del país podría ser
una socialista.
Pero ¿Qué significa exactamente socialismo
democrático? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver.
UNA IMPORTACIÓN EUROPEA
SOCIALDEMOCRACIA, seguro que más de uno ha
escuchado esta palabra en algún momento.
En realidad, uno de los partidos más importantes
de toda Europa es el partido socialdemócrata.
Por ejemplo, el partido socialista español
está encuadrado dentro de esta gran familia
ideológica. Pero ¿De dónde viene la socialdemocracia?
Pues… tenemos que irnos a principios del
Siglo XX.
En el año 1917 estalla la revolución Bolchevique
en Rusia. De repente, el país más extenso
de Europa da un giro radical a su sistema
político y decide apostar por el marxismo
lenininismo ¿Cuáles son los principios del
marxismo? Pues en este vídeo lo explicamos
más a fondo. Lo cierto es que, desde el primer
momento, los bolcheviques rusos tenían una
bocación internacional. Por eso, en 1919
crearon el llamado COMINTERN. Una organización
que englobaba a los partidos comunistas de
todo el mundo. Su objetivo era ayudar, tanto
con formación como con dinero, a todos los
partidos que quisieran seguir los pasos de
Rusia. En otras palabras, todos aquellos que
querían una revolución comunista. Pero…
como en todo en esta vida, el diablo está
en los detalles. Y hay un detalle muy importante
cuando hablamos de la revolución comunista.
Atentos.
Los comunistas no quieren conciliar sus principios
ni sus objetivos. Declaran abiertamente que
sus fines deben ser conseguidos mediante el
derrocamiento por la fuerza de todas las condiciones
sociales preexistentes. –Manifiesto Comunista,
capítulo IV.
¡Exacto! Los comunistas buscaban acabar con
el capitalismo mediante la violencia. Y aquí
es donde surge la gran brecha dentro de los
movimientos de inspiración marxista. Por
un lado, estaban los comunistas puros, que
querían revolución. Por el otro, los llamados
socialdemócratas, cuyo principal referente
sería Rosa de Luxemburgo. Básicamente, los
socialdemócratas querían acabar con el capitalismo
usando las herramientas de la democracia liberal.
Es decir, presentarse a las elecciones y,
poco a poco, cambiar las leyes hasta terminar
llegando a un sistema socialista.
Para los comunistas rusos, los socialdemócratas
eran unos traidores a la clase obrera. Si
duermes con el enemigo, tarde o temprano te
terminarás uniendo a él.
Pero lo cierto es que los partidos socialdemócratas
funcionaron muy bien en toda Europa. Al menos,
desde el punto de vista electoral. Y, sin
duda alguna, la zona donde del mundo donde
más poder consiguieron fueron los países
escandinavos. Suecia, Dinamarca y Noruega
tuvieron gobiernos socialdemócratas durante
décadas. Y por eso, todos estos países tienen
estados del bienestar muy generosos, con sanidad
universal, muchísimos servicios públicos
y, por supuesto, impuestos altos.
Y por eso, seguro que todos habréis oído
a muchos políticos defender el “modelo
nórdico”. Entre otros, nuestra amiga Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez. Cada vez que alguien la acusa
de querer acabar con las libertades y la democracia
Estadounidense, ella dice que su modelo es
Suecia y Dinamarca. Y ¡Oye! A ver quién
dice que no a eso. A fin de cuentas, tanto
Suecia como Dinamarca tienen estándares de
vida fantásticos ¿Quién no querría vivir
en Copenhague, con un sueldo de más de 3000
dólares al mes, colegios y hospitales públicos?
¿Verdad?
Pero la pregunta que nos deberíamos hacer
es ¿De verdad podemos decir que los países
escandinavos son socialistas? Pues… ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
EL MODELO NÓRDICO
Los comunistas tenían razón en una cosa:
si segues las reglas de los burgueses, terminas
convirtiéndote en uno de ellos. Y eso es
exactamente lo que ocurrió con todos estos
partidos socialdemócratas. Poco a poco, todos
ellos terminaron abandonando el marxismo y
el anticapitalismo. De hecho, si véis este
vídeo desde España, recordaréis el congreso
de Suresnes, con Felipe González, donde el
PSOE abandonó rechazó oficialmente el marxismo
en su programa electoral.
Lo cierto es que la premisa básica del socialismo
marxista es la propiedad social de los medios
de producción.¡Ojo! Esto es algo muy importante
de matizar. Un comunista no tiene problemas
con que tú tengas tu propia casa o tu propio
iPhone. Eso son bienes de consumo, es decir,
que los utilizas para tu vida diaria. El problema
está en tener fábricas, empresas o máquinas
con las que puedas producir bienes para vender
en el mercado. Eso es lo que, en economía
se llaman bienes de producción o de capital.
Y ahí es donde los comunistas no son amigos
de la propiedad privada. Repito que todo esto
lo explicamos más a fondo en un vídeo que
os dejo en la descripción. Por cierto que,
si os interesan estos temas, recordad que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a VisualPolitik y dadle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Pero, seguimos con la historia.
Os preguntaréis ¿Y esto cómo se consigue?
¿Qué significa socializar los medios de
producción? Pues hay muchas formas de colectivizar
el capital. Desde nacionalizar empresas hasta
crear cooperativas donde los trabajadores
también son accionistas.
Y diréis ¿Hay muchas cooperativas en Suecia?
Pues… lo cierto es que no. De hecho, si
hay una tendencia en estos países es, precisamente,
a todo lo contrario.
Suecia lidera el ranking the privatizaciones
Ningún país ha privatizado y desregulado
servicios públicos tan rápido como Suecia,
según un estudio del think tank conservador,
fundación Heritage
Para que os hagáis una idea, la fundación
Heritage publica todos los años un ranking
de libertad económica en el mundo. Según
este ranking, Estados Unidos es la 12º economía
más libre del mundo. Dinamarca es la 14º
y Suecia la 19º. Durante los últimos 20
años, estos países han privatizado casi
todas las empresas públicas. Incluso en algunos
aspectos, Suecia es bastante más capitalista
que Estados Unidos. Por ejemplo, el sistema
educativo. Estados Unidos fue uno de los primeros
países del mundo en garantizar educación
universal. Y esta educación se da en colegios
públicos, pagados y gestionados por el Gobierno,
bien sea a nivel federal o estatal. El caso
de Suecia es distinto. En este caso, tenemos
cada vez más escuelas privadas compitiendo
con las públicas. Por supuesto, el estado
garantiza que todos los ciudadanos puedan
recibir educación. Pero a los ciudadanos
se les da el dinero y son ellos quienes, a
título individual, pueden elegir el colegio
donde quieren llevar a sus hijos. A este sistema
se le llama “cheque escolar”. Y algo parecido
ocurre en la sanidad, donde cada vez están
entrando más y más empresas privadas. Y
algo parecido ocurre en Dinamarca. Para que
os hagáis una idea, en estos dos países,
ni siquiera existe un salario mínimo. Sí,
sí. Habéis oído bien. Por supuesto que
existen políticas de protección de los trabajadores
y seguros de desempleo. Pero no tienen salario
mínimo. Así que cuando Ocasio Cortez propone
un sueldo base, regulado por el estado, de
15 dólares la hora… no sé de donde lo
habrá sacado pero, desde luego, no de los
países nórdicos. Y todo esto explica las
declaraciones que dio el Primer Ministro Danés
en una visita oficial a Estados Unidos.
Sé que hay algunos en Estados Unidos que
asocian el modelo nórdico con un tipo de
socialismo. Así que me gustaría dejar una
cosa clara: Dinamarca está lejos de ser una
economía planificada socialista. Dinamarca
es una economía de mercado.
Es verdad que algunos impuestos son más altos
que en Estados unidos. Por ejemplo, en Dinamarca,
el tipo marginal de impuesto sobre la renta
puede llegar hasta el 56%. Pero esto también
implica un sistema fiscal muchísimo más
estable. Pensadlo bien, en Estados Unidos,
la deuda ya supera el 105% del PIB. Es decir,
que el Gobierno debe dos veces toda la economía
que genera el país en un año. En Dinamarca,
la deuda no supera el 35%. Y lo mismo pasa
con el déficit. Es decir, que la Casa Blanca
gasta mucho más de lo que ingresa. Y, en
el largo plazo, eso puede traer problemas.
En otras palabras, que por raro que suene,
los países escandinavos ofrecen muchísima
más estabilidad para los negocios. Y todo
esto explica que haya tantísimas empresas
privadas nacidas en esta zona del mundo. Por
ejemplo, H&M, la cadena de tiendas de ropa,
o Spotify, el servicio de música en streaming,
son compañías suecas.
Por supuesto que hay muchas propuestas de
Ocasio Cortez o de Bernie Sanders que sí
podrían encajar con el sistema nórdico.
Por ejemplo, la sanidad universal. Pero hay
muchas otras que, buenas o malas, no tienen
nada que ver con el modelo nórdico.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros ¿Creéis
que esta nueva oleada de políticas demócratas
llegará a tomar el control del partido? ¿Vamos
a ver una nueva revolución ideológica, al
igual que la que estamos viendo dentro del
partido republicano? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto.